last night I was going I was an event
about to go on stage my phone rang and I
looked and it was Sherelle Greiner
calling me a number I was very surprised
that she was calling at that particular
time and I thought what could this be
and I so I started asking her about her
day she said about a week ago she got a
call from the White House that says
we're feeling optimistic but she had no
idea what that meant on Tuesday she got
a call that says you need to go to
Washington for a meeting with Jake
Sullivan again she said she's very
nervous she's is it good news is it bad
news and she started thinking why would
they call me to Washington if it was
good news wouldn't they just tell me
that she goes not really knowing what to
expect and when she gets to Washington
they said the president would like to
see you she goes into the Oval Office
and she said the first thing Joe Biden
said to her was we got her
which which he said it just took me a
minute to process exactly what that
means because she was told coming to
Washington uh Thursday you'll be flying
back to Phoenix that's what she thought
she thought she'd be flying back to
Phoenix on Thursday so she had a ticket
to come home yeah but she said she was
so nervous because she didn't know what
was happening what a what a year 12
months ago you know you're not walking
in the Oval Office
of your wife and dealing with the
president and they hear that news uh
what a whirlwind and you see why they
kept it so quiet the White House was so
concerned about it leaking right that
they gave her very little details and
she said but once she got in they said
there was going to be a news conference
and they asked her do you want to be in
the audience do you want to stand beside
me do you not want to be in the room and
she was so thankful and so so grateful
to President Biden and vice president
Kamala Harris she said I will stand
beside the two of you because you are
bringing my wife home needless to say
she's still on cloud nine she said Gail
I have a a I have a I'm smiling so much
smiling so much my face hurts it was
great at the press conference where she
let herself smile she said you know what
I'm just gonna I'm gonna smile right now
and she wasn't frowning for the last
long time and she wore red yesterday
guys because it was Britney's favorite
color so there you go she was gonna be
reunited with Brittany at four o'clock
this morning we will see we'll get more
about that